♪♪
-♪ When you wish upon a star ♪
-♪ Makes no difference
who you are ♪
-♪ Anything your heart desires
will come to ♪
♪ Supercalifragilistic-
expialidocious ♪
♪ Even though the sound of it is
something quite atrocious ♪
♪ If you say it loud enough,
you'll always sound precocious ♪
♪ Supercalifragilistic-
expialidocious ♪
♪♪
♪ Heigh-ho, heigh-ho,
it's off to work we go ♪
-[ Whistling ]
-♪ Heigh-ho,
heigh-ho, heigh-ho, heigh-ho ♪
♪ Look for the bare
necessities ♪
♪ The simple bare necessities ♪
♪ Forget about your worries
and your strife ♪
-♪ Under the sea ♪
♪ Under the sea ♪
♪ Darling, it's better
down where it's wetter ♪
♪ Take it from me ♪
-But, Jimmy...
♪ I want to be where
the people are ♪
♪ I want to see,
want to see 'em dancin' ♪
♪ Walkin' around on those,
whad'ya call 'em? ♪
♪ Oh, feet, duh ♪
♪ Up where they walk,
up where they run ♪
♪ Up where they stay
all day in the sun ♪
♪ Wanderin' free,
wish I could be ♪
♪ Part of that world ♪
-♪ A whole new world ♪
-♪ A new fantastic
point of view ♪
♪ No one to tell us no ♪
♪ Or where to go ♪
♪ Or say we're only dreaming ♪
-♪ Certain as the sun ♪
-♪ Rising in the east ♪
-♪ Tale as old as time ♪
-♪ Song as old as rhyme ♪
-♪ Beauty and the beast ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Nants ingonyama bagithi baba!
♪ Can you feel the love
tonight? ♪
-♪ Have you ever heard the wolf
cry to the blue corn moon ♪
-♪ Do you want to build
a snowman? ♪
-♪ Or asked the grinning
bobcat why he grins? ♪
-♪ It doesn't have
to be a snowman ♪
-Go away, Jimmy.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jimmy, wait.
♪♪
Come here.
♪ You've got a friend in me ♪
-♪ Yeah, you've got
a friend in me ♪
-♪ You just remember what
your old pal said ♪
-♪ You've got a friend in me ♪
♪♪
-♪ Remember me ♪
♪ Though I have to say goodbye ♪
♪ Don't let it make you cry ♪
♪♪
♪ See the line where the sky
meets the sea? ♪
♪ It calls me ♪
-♪ And no one knows,
how far it goes ♪
♪ Every day's a little harder
as I feel my power grow ♪
♪ Don't you know there's part
of me that longs to go ♪
-♪ Into the unknown? ♪
♪ Into the unknown? ♪
♪ Into the unknow-- ♪
-Jimmy! Jimmy! Jimmy?
♪♪
♪ Let it go, let it go ♪
♪ Can't hold it back anymore ♪
♪ Turn away and slam the door ♪
♪ I don't care
what they're going to say ♪
♪ Let the storm rage on ♪
♪ The cold never bothered me
anyway ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Aah! Look at that!
Come on!